Hey! Welcome to a new Project Kamp update!
It's early in the morning, because we're going to go to a cork factory.
Where they're going to harvest the cork.
In a farm and in a factory,
where they’re going to produce it into useful things.
So, we're going to see how the process works.
It should be exciting!
So, yeah, like Dave said before,
it's six in the morning.
So, the streets are still empty.
The landscape is beautiful, covered in thick fog.
The early sun just started to reach out,
with its first golden sunbeams.
We are making our way in Dave’s shakey van on the highway.
A 2,5 hour drive is awaiting us.
First stop is the cork factory called Sofalca.
Located somewhere in the countryside,
between Project Kamp and Lisbon.
There, we're going to meet Charles.
He runs a company called Corklink,
who is the local supplier for a variety of cork products.
He was kind enough to invite us for a tour,
around the cork tree farms and the factory.
We met him at the parking place of the factory.
We jumped in his car, because it's a bit faster
And, we continued further south to the cork tree fields.
So, let's see what is waiting there for us!
It looks like you're in Africa!
- Safari time!
There are the lions, giraffes...
- So, Dave, where are we now?
So, we're currently at a cork field with a lot of cork trees.
We're going to see how they're going
to get harvested, how it works...
To see what a day of a cork harvester looks like.
- Why is it shaking so much?
We're in the back of a pickup truck,
because they're a little hard to access.
All right, so, we're now at the cork harvest place!
Here, we have Charles!
He's going to give us a little bit of a tour,
about how the harvesting process works.
- Well...
We're in Southern Portugal here.
Where most of the cork trees grow in Portugal.
During the summer months, all of the cork forests in Portugal
have their barks stripped.
The guys you can see working here travel around Central
and Southern Portugal, taking the bark off the trees in teams.
So, you can see that the technique they use
is they have an extremely sharp ax.
And, they bash at the tree to just cut the bark.
They have to hit the bark with just the right amount of strength,
so that the bark gets cracked open.
But, they don't damage the membrane
that's inside the bark covering the tree.
Because, if you damage that membrane,
then the tree can die.
So, these guys, it looks like
they're just smacking away at the tree.
But, actually, it's a finely judged amount of force
that they're using to hit the trees.
So, that the bark will fall off naturally.
And, funny enough, each of these guys' ax is their own personal ax,
and they treat it like their pride and joy.
It's like a concert violinist with their violin.
They won't let anyone else touch their ax,
and they sharpen it all day long.
It has just the right weight for them.
They know exactly how hard to whack the tree,
when they're taking the cork off.
The cork can only be removed every nine years.
Because, otherwise, you don't have enough thickness in the cork,
to be able to use it to make wine corks.
The joy of cork is that taking this bark off the tree,
it does no damage at all to it.
The cork will growback.
So, nine years later, you can harvest the cork again.
In fact, some of these trees around here are 200 years old!
They've been harvested every nine years, for 200 years!
Nothing happens quickly in cork forests.
So, a young tree like this one here,
which is maybe four or five years old...
It's not ready to give up quality cork,
until it's 15 or 20 years old.
So, the first seven or eight years,
the cork tree's just left to grow.
And then, afterwards, you can see this tree here...
This has been harvested once, so it's had its first harvest
and this is the regrowth.
You can see that the original cork is here, which hasn't been harvested at all.
So, this is the regrowth here.
The first harvest of the cork is called virgin cork,
and it's extremely resinous.
You can't use it to make wine corks.
So, that's generally used to make expanded cork.
The second harvest is generally a reasonable quality cork,
but it's not the best quality...
The best quality comes in the third, fourth, or fifth harvest.
And, some of these trees around here are 200 years old.
They can give some fabulous quality cork,
which is used for natural wine corks of the best quality.
These amazing cork forests in Portugal
are actually also a fabulous carbon sink.
Because, these trees, they'll grow for 200 years or more.
Whilst with other wood products, you have to cut the tree down,
and that ends its purpose of absorbing carbon.
These cork trees carry on growing forever,
so you're just removing the bark.
And, meanwhile, the tree every year for its entire lifespan...
It's sucking carbon dioxide out of the atmosphere.
And, all that's left over is the cork bark,
which is processed into cork to make a biodegradable product.
So, it's really the perfect, sustainable product
for the 21st century and beyond.
So, the cork they harvested is put on this truck,
which goes to the factory.
And then, in the factory, they’re going to process it into things.
They’re going to granulate it, chop it...
So, we're going to now have a look at the factory,
to see how it's being processed.
After the harvest, we went to a factory where they process it.
It turns out there are three different ways to process the cork:
Natural, agglomerated and expanded cork.
Here, Charles explains the difference,
using the classic wine stopper as an example.
So, you saw in the forest that we took off
those big planks of cork off the trees.
Well, that's the first step into making natural wine corks.
So, those big planks we saw in
the forest are now cut up into strips.
This would be the outside of the tree,
and here would be the inside of the tree.
Then, to make a natural wine cork,
which is the most premium kind of wine cork...
You literally have a punch.
And, it punches through the cork,
and pushes the cork out the other side.
At the end of it, you have a natural cork.
So, natural corks, the most prized kind of corks,
and you see a very premium wine cork looks like this.
With almost no imperfections on the surface of it.
So, to get really good quality wine corks,
you need to have really good quality cork.
Once you've made the wine corks,
you have all this leftover cork.
What happens to this?
It gets granulated turned into granules,
and then those granules can be glued together.
To make either to make boards like this one,
which you see for flooring or for notice boards.
Or, they can be made into agglomerated wine corks.
So, the agglomerated wine cork is much more uniform, than a natural wine cork,
But, of course, it isn't 100% natural, because the granules have
to be glued together to make agglomerated cork.
What’s left after all of that cork has been used
for agglomerated cork and natural cork?
It's rotten bits of cork, which no one really wants...
So, for example, the branches of the trees,
which have been trimmed, like this one.
This is what we've come to see today.
It's how all this waste cork, which can't be used for anything else...
How it can be turned into an amazing insulation material,
which is expanded cork.
And then, this bark can then be agglomerated,
using a different process to make expanded cork.
One of the key differences about this expanded cork,
is that unlike the agglomerated cork here...
The expanded cork is made in a different way.
The resin, which is present in the cork branches itself,
is used to bind the expanded cork granules together.
So, this is a 100% natural product,
just like natural corks are.
- You would say this thing is cool?
100% natural? Straight from the bark?
Yeah!
- This one less because you need glue?
It’s cool that it's leftovers, but you need glue to put it together...
This thing is also 100% natural,
because the resin in the cork tree glues it all together.
- That's exactly right!
What's amazing about this whole process, is that from the bark
that comes off the tree: not one grain is wasted!
It can all be used in different ways.
And, in fact, the dust that's produced,
when you're doing this process...
It's then used to make energy for the factories,
to be able to treat the cork itself.
It's a completely circular process.
So, are we going to have a look at the factory?
- Let's go!
Here, you can see the factory.
At this one, they make expanded cork.
The one that is granulated, but processed 100% natural,
because the resin in the tree is the glue.
The factory looks peaceful from up here,
however, the factory's loud.
Shredders, steam, compressed air floating around...
You can't hear anything on camera,
so we got a tour from the boss.
A very nice guy!
I'll narrate the process for you, once we get inside.
So, let's start at the beginning of making expanded cork.
The raw material!
They have mountains of cork!
So, here we are, at an expanded cork factory.
Expanded cork is one of the most amazing
insulation materials to ever come across.
100% natural and a fantastic insulator!
And, what's one of the really great things about it is this:
For expanded cork, we use the really rough bits of cork,
that no one else wants to use.
So, this cork I've got in my hand here,
and this massive pile you can see behind me...
It's scraps of cork that essentially no one else wants to use.
And here, at the factory, we’re going to see
how we’re going to take this cork...
Granulate it, and sort it, so we get the best bits that we need.
To make the insulation expanded cork boards
And then, make it into big blocks,
which can then be cut into sheets of expanded cork.
To insulate your home or whatever else needs insulating.
So, let's go and visit a factory!
The first step is to filter out the piles of cork.
Because, all the cork is leftover and mixed with sand and stones...
But, also wood from the cork tree itself
can still be stuck on the bark...
So, they throw it into big machines
that shake it and get the rough dirt out.
And then, the shredder,
that chops it into small granules.
They're transported on screws and conveyor belts.
All with different systems to filter out unwanted materials!
At this point, it's a mix of different granule sizes of cork,
so they also separate them.
The small ones can be used for expanding,
and will be used for biomass.
The large ones will go back in the system to shred again...
The medium size continues the process.
This is what the granules look like
after sorting and shredding.
Then, they go into this beast: the boiler.
Here, they use the biomass leftover from before,
to heat it up and produce steam from water.
He mentioned that the boiler was installed in the seventies,
and it's still running!
A very basic and durable machine.
The room down here is fired up
every morning at seven, until midnight.
It’s 1000 degrees in there!
Yeah, we didn't go in...
Then, it goes to the next step, which is the core
of the process: the actual pressing.
Here, the core granules go into a big metal mold.
In this case, the shape of a big rectangular block.
Once of the mold is full, they close it, heat it up,
and with steam and heat...
The cork expands and the resin comes out.
Meanwhile, it's pressed together with a big hydraulic press.
The process of filling the mold, heating it up,
and taking it out takes about 20 minutes.
And once it comes out, the block
has a deep brown color because of the heat.
The cork itself doesn't burn, but just turns dark.
But, inside these blocks, you can actually
see a few little red glowing things.
These are little pieces of wood,
that didn't manage to filter out.
They did burn and turned into charcoal.
But, the amount of wood is minimal,
so it's not really a problem.
And, from there, the block is cut open,
so it can cool down faster.
With water being sprinkled on top.
At this point, you have a solid block of expanded cork.
Naturally glued together with just heat and pressure.
These blocks will rest outside for a few weeks.
So they get rid of all the tension inside...
And then, to the final step: cutting.
Here, the blocks are brought in and cut to size.
The blocks feel solid, but are lightweight!
The popular purpose for them is insulation,
since it has a high 'R'-value.
But, it also has a few other cool properties!
As for instance, you saw before the wood burnt
and the cork didn’t.
So, it's very fire resistant and it's 100% natural material,
which is very unique for an insulator.
Some people use it between walls, roofs,
floors, or even directly on the outside.
The application defines the thickness you need.
Thinner for the walls, and thicker for the roofs.
So, this is the end result: sheets of expanded cork.
You can have them in different sizes and thicknesses.
We want to use this for our ruin as an insulation material.
We need to figure out what's the size we want,
and what the thickness is.
So, we need to do some calculations and measurements.
But, yeah, we're going to see more
about that later on!
Alright, so, that was it for this video!
If you already want to see the next one for next week,
make sure to subscribe on Patreon!
If not, you’ll just see us here next week.
Same channel, same time!
Thanks for watching!